President Trump is set to officially
start his re-election campaign tomorrow
in Florida leaked polls from his own
campaign show it's one of several key
states where he trails potential
Democratic challenger Joe Biden mr.
Trump calls the polls fake his campaign
says they were created to test a
worst-case scenario for the president
our first CBS News 20/20 battleground
tracker poll shows likely Democratic
voters prefer Biden as their first
choice to go head-to-head with mr. Trump
Ouisa jiang is at the White House we
show how else is the Trump campaign
responding to this leak polling data
oh good morning Tony CBS News has
learned that Trump campaign fired
several pollsters after those internal
polling numbers were leaked tomorrow
President Trump is planning to hold a
big festival and rally for his
re-election run in Orlando Florida a
state that helped propel him to victory
in 2016 but it's not a given in 2020 I
don't think anybody has done more in
two-and-a-half years than what I've done
president Trump says he's not relying on
a pitch to persuade voters to reelect
him because his record is plenty safety
security great economy and I think I've
done more than any other first term
president ever
but 2020 comes with new challenges the
Trump campaigns internal polling shows
the president trailing former Vice
President Joe Biden in critical
battleground states 39 to 55% in
Pennsylvania 41 to 51 in Wisconsin and
by 7 points in Florida the Trump team
says the poll is from March though mr.
Trump has repeatedly denied it existed
at all those polls don't exist
those poles don't exist still he's
zooming in on Biden he's still leading
the polls on the Democratic side is
tightening up a little bit and a lot
which is interesting but he's still
beating you Gordon well I don't believe
those balls the new CBS News
battleground tracker shows 55% of likely
Democratic voters are considering
supporting Biden with Elizabeth Warren
Kamala Harris and Bernie Sanders on his
heels this weekend the candidates looked
past each other and went after President
Trump somebody who actually served in
the military when it was his turn
somebody with a totally different style
like me is about as opposite as it gets
I think frankly I am the strongest
candidate to defeat from our CBS News
battleground tracker shows that is the
right strategy 69 percent of Democrats
say they want to hear their candidates
talking about beating President Trump in
2020 while just 31 percent want to hear
about trying to impeach him the
president appeared to reference the pole
in this tweet last night claiming almost
70 percent say don't impeach but the
poll only asked what Democrats want
their candidates to talk about not what
they want them to do Tony all right
Louie thank you and I want to bring in
CBS News elections and surveys director
Anthony salvato is here at the table
with us Anthony we are a year and a half
ahead of an election what's the point of
an internal poll so far out messaging
because you're right it's a year and a
half away things can change but the
campaign's do this so they can figure
out how to launch their campaign what to
talk about and what voters want to hear
in order to move the needle that's
really the most important part of
polling at this point yeah find
something out about the go ahead yeah
but I was going to say but but remember
the election that comes first which is
the Democrats who need to pick a
candidate to go against the president
and you know they see them testing
against Joe Biden there's a reason for
that and it's because Joe Biden is
leading that field in our in our polling
but I will add then when you ask people
who they're considering voting for not
just who they're voting for because that
elections a while away - yeah well you
see it's not just Biden but there's also
Harris in the mix
Anders Elizabeth Warren although all of
those are in voters minds as they're
sort of kicking the time everybody still
be working out their their messaging
we're gonna be working out our analysis
on the polls in the eight o'clock hour
with Anthony you'll be back you got
that's in the next hour for more on the
first CBS News 2020 battleground tracker
poll in that poll we asked thousands of
Democratic voters in the earliest
primary and caucus states what they're
looking for in a candidate that is